[موسيقى]
حتى لا يستفيد شيئا مع الاسف لانه هو اداه
فقط مع الاسف الشديد ويقدم هذا الدعم رغما
عنه هو لا يستفيد اي شيء في كل مستويات
لكنه يقدم يشبه جميلا للاطراف التي كانت
تدعمه في السنوات الماضيه وهذه الاطراف
التي تحرش الان من تقديم الدعم بشكل مباشر
لحميتي في السودان لا تجد سوى خليه حفتر
الطرف الجاهل دائما للاستخدام في ليبيا
لتقديم هذا الدعم
لحميتي في السودان كان هذا الدعم يسبب
لحفتر احراجا كبيرا جدا مما ادى اوساهم في
تغيير مسارات هذا الدعم لتكون في شكل اخر
على الاقل اقل بالنسبه لحفتر من
مكان عليه في السابق
الاسلحه التي يخشى حتى ان تضرب جويا في
تلك الصحراء الان هذه الاسلحه التي كانت
خائر وكانت مضادات جويه وكانت صواريخ 7
وهي صواريخ اغلبها
لم ياتي من الخارج لاغلبها كان موجودا
بالفعل في ليبيا وتم تقديمه في بدايه
الامر
في في بدايه الامر كانت يقدم بشكل شبه
مباشر من قواعد في ابراجها قاعده الخادم
في شرق البلاد ثم بعد ذلك يذهب به الى
مطار الكوفره وهي بنده في الحدود مع
السودان بعد ذلك يذهب به عن طريق شاحنات
صغيره بالنسبه للوقود الذي كان ياتي عن
طريق صفات السرير في شرق البلاد بعد مرور
قرابه الشهر من الحرس في السودان واصبحت
هذه المسارات صعبه جدا خصوصا بعد فتره
الجيش السوداني على مواقع ابرزها قاعده
شيفروليه السودانيه في بالقرب من الحديد
الليبيه الان يقدم هذا الدعم من قواعد في
ليبيا الى قواعد في بانكي في افريقيا
الوسطى بعد ذلك يتم تسليمه الى السودان عن
طريق بانجي وهذا ما كان عليه الدعم الان
حاليا لكن مع انه قل قليلا لكنه ما يزال
مستمر وما يزال يقدم بهذه الطريقه